if multiplayer teams worked like high
school sports teams I would be picked
last pretty much every time not because
I don't play a lot of games or because
I'm particularly bad at them but because
I've never really had a knack for
multiplayer shooters due to my dislike
of competitive gaming and my general
inability to aim it's a big part of why
I usually just avoid them since for me
that's synonymous with avoiding
embarrassment there's only so many times
you can die and spot your name at the
bottom of the leaderboard before it's
just not fun anymore but then I got a
chance to play battleborn gearboxes take
on the hero shooter genre a place the
blizzards overwatch sits in more
specifically I got to play the MOBA ask
incursion multiplayer mode where two
teams of five fight alongside waves of
AI to push their way into the
opposition's base after flipping through
literally all 25 characters i opted for
a guardian looking chick called galilea
who fights with the sword and a shield
yep this shooter also includes a number
of characters who in fact don't shoot
half an hour or so later the match ended
we'd one and I was at the top of the
leaderboard most kills most assists
highest score and wondering what the
hell just happened well here's what
happened I knew from the start that I
wanted to go for one of the male
characters because of my whole [ __ ] at
aiming thing in addition to being way
more confident Russian to the front of
the pack and doing close range / e
damage galilea was a perfect pic with a
shield and suit of armor she wasn't so
squishy that she was being sniped
immediately by the gun-toting characters
and as soon as I could get her in close
nine out of ten times it spelled the end
for my opponent and not me for the first
time in my gaming life I played a
multiplayer game that catered to the
strengths I had to offer to a PPP team a
play style based on aggression speed and
fast brutal melee combat I think that's
what feels so promising about battle
born to me it really feels is that there
are so many uniquely different combat
styles among 25 different characters
which will hopefully play to the
strengths of different kinds of players
I'm pretty sure anyone could and
probably will find the character or
characters who work best the way they
liked play
much like dota 2 and street fighter
players do that said unlike those games
battleborn doesn't have terribly
complicated systems and it's pretty easy
to pick up and play even if you don't
know the mechanics you point your chute
you get up to three special abilities to
use and the only resource you really
need to worry about is your health a
common point of comparison for
battleborn ears hero shooter overwatch
but with only one true male focus
character reinhart it doesn't appear to
have the same flexibility in play style
that I find so exciting in battle born
it's still very attached to the idea of
being shooter and while that's great for
those who excel at range the buck pretty
much stops there for the rest of us like
overwatch many multiplayer shooters
cater to different kinds of gunplay but
battleborn throws in all manner of sword
fighters and brawlers on top of their
different types of ranged attackers
healers and supports it feels like
battle born balances them all out in a
way that leads me to think it has the
potential to be much more accessible
than team shooters like over what
another factor which led me to feel this
way is that the size of the incursion
map I played on was pretty small so it
was easier to stick close to your team
get back to the frontline and contribute
to extra tasks along the way like
liberating AI mercenary camps to get
your team some extra grunts or collect
shards which can be used to build towers
and other defenses those kinds of tasks
are especially attractive to plays who
may not feel confident enough to help
out on the front line without a doubt
this is the kind of game that will
undergo a whole lot of rebalancing
before it releases that said this could
be the kind of multiplayer game that
your friends can not only easily get on
board with but also find that they're on
a relatively level playing field for I'm
excited about the idea of a multiplayer
shooter which appears to be flattening
the barrier to entry where players of
all levels and expertise can find their
own niche play styling
acta especially those gamers who may
have thought they wouldn't or couldn't
enjoy themselves in a game like this one
because I'll tell you what for seeing
your name at the top of the leaderboard
bloody fantastic powerful enemy forces
at forty percent rate